after 3 to S years Edward Gib even talks
about this that the Romans came back and
defeated the Persians how did the
prophet Muhammad know
this by the grace of Allah subhah wa
taala the response has been overwhelming
to say the very least alhamdulillah
we've had social media personalities and
respected Scholars sh from many parts of
the Muslim world promoting the cause we
have raised almost 1.4 million
alhamdulillah and we haven't been
sitting idy waiting to hit our Target of
2 million we have fully purchased four
properties in London transferred their
ownership to the W after the help of
Allah subhanahu wa taala none of this
would be possible without your support
so we thank you once again this is our
update to yourselves we encourage you to
stay tuned for more update now that the
work alhamdulillah is truly underway
thousands of years in history before
but now apparently this is the right way
because it was written by a
con to and advantage of Roman Empire
Jack Jack speak to this guy Jack speak
to this guy no no it's fine it's fine
it's fine no it's fine it's fine
list now you're talking about the
prophet muham coner name me a
single which at the time Vin tribes that
were spread across Arabia time and then
the Eastern Roman Empire and the
Persians had a massive war were both
defe in terms of manow and motivation
and Prophet Muhammad took advantage of
that situation and conquered Persia and
then took Eastern you don't know that
you don't know no I do know that we have
records you know when the
mus we know the Muslim we know the
Muslim when they
the wasn't
in history religion has been used as a
way of maintaining it's been a way
galvanizing not the that is
not you can say about Christianity who
they did crde European I agree India
and just as bad ultimately religious no
no Christianity is done if you look at
statistics there's one one podon
Christian Islam is six in the most death
that's been caused Christianity is
number one over 275 million then it's
atheism Islam is six in that list reason
being is a lot of people look at
religion and look at what Crusaders done
and they they try to complicit Islam
with them Islam is nowhere near it why
because number one Islam believes in
expansionism we believe in that we don't
deny that however we do not believe in
the expansionism the West has been doing
Imperial powers and what Christianity
has been doing which is by the sword but
how is any different very different I'll
tell you how for example wherever Islam
has spread if you look for example look
at if you you look up for example
England you have the crown jewels you go
to the British museum there are artifact
there that have been stolen by Egypt by
Africa and different countries yeah good
why is it then Islam Islam is Holy City
the main city is what Mecca do you find
the crown jewels there do you find any
diamonds there do you find any uh things
that have been stolen from the Empire
Islam ruled and brought back to Mecca no
you don't consider the amount of wealth
that would have been conquered from
North Africa no no no but what I'm say
absolutely Mansa was one of the richest
men to this Earth yes and he was a
Muslim yes and wherever he went the
amount of gold that he gave so the thing
is in Islam wherever they went even when
they went to Egypt when Egypt Muslims
conquered Egypt they didn't touch the
statues and all that kind of stuff Islam
did not go there to rob the people of
their wealth rather they invested that
money back into the people and in our
Quran it clearly says there is no
compulsion in religion so when Islam
conquers lands it is not allowed to
force conversion of anybody in
Christianity it's the opposite when they
would go they would kill men women and
children and where did they get this
from look at Israel today what's
Benjamin n quoted amikit amikit is in
the book of Samuel 15:23 Go and Kill men
women and children in Islam we don't
have a single passage a single verse
that gives us a direct commandment of
War to kill men women children or babies
Christianity in the old scripture Jesus
is the god of the Old Testament has
directly commanded go kill men women and
children that's why Israel today
alongside America and the the Christian
Lobby that is supporting Israel to kill
men women and children show me an
Islamic empire that has gone into lands
and slaughtered men women or children it
is not in our religion so please don't
conflate us I understand it might you
might not know but Crusaders have done
that but please give me an example cuz
you you're laughing I would like to know
please bring me evidence where Islam has
said you can go and kill men women and
children and force them to Islam I don't
know whether I don't know whether Islam
has said it or not but tell me where
tell me turkey and the and the look at
turkey and the what about turkey the
genocide of the Greeks that lived on
asan there's a whole discussion about
them and the Armenians there's a whole
discussion if that happened or not of
course there is whole discussion if it
happened or not of course no if it
happened or not and also what's turkey
did happen no no no according to
according to whether it happened
according to who to who to who and and
even no it didn't of asan minor was on
the C even even if it did not for debate
even if it's not religious Point let's
go with the argument did what's it got
to do with Islam okay fine you can from
religion but the bottom line is but you
said Islam teaches this and conquer no
no no I never said that okay I never
said that are you saying that to my
friend I said I said that organized
religion yeah in my opinion is wrong
because it's manipulated by what's your
definition of organized religion well
any kind of organized religion scripture
a church what about what about what
about secularism do you do you meem them
to be a religious in what in what sense
well well to be honest to me anyone that
follows a specific way of life and
believes that that is superior to other
is a form of religion just because you
that's not necessarily the defined way
of irrelevant because they operate like
a religion if your problem with a
religion is that they are you know
working a certain way and the conquer
lands imperialism has done that more
than ever atheism has done that maang is
one of the people have killed 70 million
people Stalin has killed 40 million
people World War I didn't start from
Muslims or Christians World War II
didn't start from Muslim or Christians
so if you go with the argument atheism
atheist were second in the line actually
after Christianity who've killed most
people I didn't even I didn't start
talking about killing people no no but
what we talking about we talking what we
talk morality talk the structure of the
church it's manipulated by man because
we have historical
records if you go back to the paganism
in ancient Greece when Alexander the
Great conquered Egypt yeah one of the
problems was is that the Egyptian gods
were very old in comparison to the to
the Greek gods yes and as a way of
building public order and building a
unified culture as it were Alexander the
Great commissioned the creation of a new
God called carapus now the idea of
carapus was to combine Osiris which was
the king of the Gods in the Egyptian
Pantheon and Zeus in the the Greek panon
and essentially went to the Egyptians
and said we're actually worshiping the
same God because Osirus and Zeus are the
same person and they created temples to
this guy called sarap exactly and the
whole reason they did that is they
manipulated it to control public war and
this can I can I interrupt just really
quickly I promise you I'll leave
back so I I am a Muslim myself so he's
just made a point
again he just made a point and then your
argument of defense is a complete
different structure of what he was
talking about that's true and again
again I I have no disrespect to either
either or religion he was talking about
one thing yeah I know again I'm not
saying anything about Christianity be
your defense of argument was on a whole
different topic compared to what he was
talking about so he was talking about
one thing and then you've gone to
something else talking about how many
people each religion has killed I never
even brought that up I never even okay
so what's your I'm what you brought up
is conversation of debate what's what's
what's your content I'm trying to
understand what is it exactly that you
have a because you talking about Islam
and the prophet Muhammad and the Pagan
Arabs and conquest and you talking about
Conquest that's what I was trying to
show you the you said to me sorry you
said to me what's your name by the way
Jack Jack so Jack you saying to me I was
talking about Conquest we was talking
about expansionism so you say What's the
difference with Islam and I gave you the
example that in Islam you are not
allowed to force people to Islam when it
comes to the the crown jewels and BR the
art if you go to British museum things
that have been stolen by the lands that
they conquered in Islam we don't have
this we don't go to Mecca and see the
diamonds so what I'm saying is Islam
came to en those but you ask
me bringing up a conversation about the
whole topic ultimately the problem I
have with any kind of organized religion
is manipulated by man we have historical
records but Islam is not that don't put
Islam that because I have evidence that
it is not if you're arguing that Islam
is
I can't not disingenuously accept the
fact that something like Quran anded
B but we can prove it we can prove it if
your argument
isan Brothers Brothers Brothers Brothers
Brothers he asking a question forgive me
we go
to no it's just it's just I want to
stick the topic so what I'm saying is
are we have evidence why it's not
manipulated manipulated by men good so
you ask that question when it comes to
the Bible do you accept the Bible has
been changed by men absolutely good
perfect not only that the Christians
admit thats you have B and Bruce Metar
these are one's an ex- Christian one's
still a Christian who's written textual
critics they have they accept this when
you open the Bible I've got my Bible
here if I bring the Bible here it has
footnotes in the footnotes it tells you
clearly this story in John 753 to Mark
81 has been added in by who men we don't
have that problem with the Quran the
Quran is when your friend asked me
what's the reason I chose Islam 11 years
ago is because Islam is the Quran is the
only religion that has not been changed
by
mankind I'm sorry I don't believe it's
not matter what you believe look but who
wrote the book look look I'm telling you
a man who wrot it's no what I'm Jack you
listen to what I'm telling you listen to
without I don't me to Rude listen to
learn not listen to reply yeah I'm the
same with you I'm trying to learn from
you as well we're trying to learn from
each other the Quran has an Evidence
within itself when I before I came to
Islam there's one verse that stood out
for me which was very clearly the Quran
says if you think this is not from your
lord bring a chapter like it it's it's a
b challenge it's telling you if you
think this is man-made produce something
like it now the smallest chapter in the
Quran is three lines one two three the
Quran is telling the Arabs this is what
challenge to the Arabs part excellent
the Arabic language linguists bring
something like it if you think it's not
now you're not an Arab you can't do that
it's not a fair challenge the next
challenge was the Quran said if this was
not from your lord you'll find many
contradictions and errors in it now I'm
telling you the Quran was revealed to
the prophet Muhammad his companions
which were men wrote sit down wasam
however the Quran has evidences and
miracles within it to prove that it's
not from God and I'll give you an
Evidence because you talked about the
the Empire the Persian Empire and the
Roman Empire in the Quran in Surah R
chapter Rome it says the following I was
reading it today actually it says the
Romans have been defeated in the nearer
land and after 3 to seven years they
would come back and win now if you read
Edward gibbers let's go to non-muslim
historians I don't want to go to Muslim
because you might say it's bias Gibbons
is an historian who looks into the Roman
Empire very in detail he he actually
looks at them in the detail of their
collapse to their rise so Edward Gibbons
is saying for example when the Persians
defeated the Romans Rome was on the
Brinks of collapse and you you might
know this now the Quran says something
very interesting if the Quran is from
man made up by the prophet Muhammad why
would the prophet Muhammad make such a
bold claim that could put his propit
hood in Jeopardy number two why would he
talk about politics what's it got to do
with with anything the Quran says
clearly now if we lived at that time and
you myself lived at time and we saw the
the fight between the Romans and the
Persians and the Persians defeated
Romans to the moment to the to the to
the level that the Rome was on the
Brinks of collapse who would you put
your bets on for the next 10
years everyone put it on Persia everyone
will put it on Persia nobody will come
and say oh I believe Rome the Romans are
going to come back the Quran says the
absolute opposite bro it's so crazy that
people are thinking the Quran says the
Romans have been defeated but in 3 to
seven years they will come back and win
the war that is a bold claim number one
number two if why would the prophet make
such a bold claim because if it doesn't
come true his entire prophethood Islam
being from God froze in the bin and why
would he take a risk like that so after
3 to seven years Edward given even talks
about this that the Romans came back and
defeated the Persians how did the
prophet Muhammad know
this is an easy prediction
it is easy tell me how don't say to me
tell me how tell me
how how because the Romans and Persians
weren well the Romans weren't defeated
St no it wasn't yes it no it wasn't yes
it Edward Gibbons is a historian he's
telling you Rome was in the brink of
collapse yes it was BR of do you know
what that means it been the brink collap
for hundreds of years no no no no no one
second no no one second one second no no
they were even going to the head of the
emperor they they even were the Persians
I think they even kidnapped M like this
yeah they did they okay good so you know
this are you you telling me the prophet
mhammad goes and says okay where should
I put my bets on I know I'm going to put
my bets on Rome only if he was a false
prophet he would say I'm going to write
the Persians have defeated the Romans
and the Persians will carry wi no one
second who okay if you lived at that
time would you come and say I put my
bets on Rome I mean to be honest if I
lived at that time I probably be
worrying about how I'm going to eat this
I know I know that but after you had
your food would you put your bet on Ro
pleasure after diverting the question I
think ultimately would put a on Ro or
you put a on Ro I would and the reason
already been around so long they had
plenty of reinforcements com but there's
a specific detail it's saying 3 to seven
years there's a specific it's not saying
it's not saying the prophet didn't say
there will come a time where the Romans
will come back no no he's saying
specific three to seven years specific
who in their right mind it's like me
saying America is on the Brinks of
collapse Donald Trump's kidnapped by
Russia and I go you know what bro in a
couple of years time Trump is going to
come back and win brother on what basis
if I went to the BET off they'll kick me
out well no Trump might not come back
but I'd bet on America yeah now let's
I'm going to give that to you for the
sake of argument and say you know what
no problem he was a very intelligent guy
the prophet Muhammad no problem I've got
hundred of these prophecies by the way
so I'm going to give you a second one
the second one is for example a
historical Miracle so in the Quran if
you look into when you read the Bible
the Bible talks about Moses and Joseph
Moses and Joseph so at the time of
Joseph the uh the scripture in the Bible
says when Joseph went to the Pharaoh
when you look at Moses it says the same
thing when Moses went to Pharaoh because
they had interactions with the rulers at
the time now something very interesting
peul happens with the Quran when you
look at in the Quran the Quran says when
Joseph went to the king it does not use
the word Pharaoh now when Allah is in
the Quran talking about Moses's
interaction it says when Moses went to
Pharaoh now the question is people were
a bit like they were thinking why is the
Quran saying King for the time of Joseph
and Moses for the time of pharaoh now we
all know that the hieroglyphics was a
dead language hieroglyphics yeah how did
they decide for the hieroglyphics they
found Ros a stone by using the RO Stone
they decipher the hieroglyphics when
they decipher the hieroglyphics they
found out there were no pharaohs at the
time when they look at that time period
at the time of Joseph which means
something very interesting how did the
prophet Muhammad how did the Quran know
that at the time of Joseph where he live
there were no pharaohs pharaohs are
those a dynasty who believed them to be
demii Gods that's why they would mify
theel because they preparing theel for
the afterlife the kings were not the
same so the Bible says Pharaoh Pharaoh
but historically that's error because
there were no pharaohs at the time of
Joseph but the Quran doesn't say that
the Quran makes that very disting
distinguishes it it says King and
Pharaoh how did the prophet Muhammad
know this historical
fact I mean there were Pharaoh no they
weren't PHA they were no they won't they
were okay go to the archist and but CLE
Patrick thei was declared PHA no I'm
telling I'm telling you at married her
she was Pharaoh egpt I'm telling you at
the time of Joseph which were maybe
hundred or even thousands of years
before Moses there were no Pharaoh
Egyptians were thousands of years old to
the ROM look look there were no pharaohs
and it's look look I'm this not
something I'm making up you can check it
out guys they were no pharaohs they were
no pharaohs one thing I'll say non
religious Islamic he's coming with facts
facts and you're you're coming with
arguments based on arguments no I'm not
I'm coming with
fact in egpt
coming and saying there's no at
guys that's fine you can fact Che look
look you can you can fact check on the
semantic no no it's not semantic you can
fact check me here there were no pharaos
it's it's it's archa look I don't go
with fact check there were no phos look
I'm saying in the comment section you
look in the comment section look you you
you you'll embarrass just be
embarrassing and and and no I just want
to stick on this because I've got I've
got multiple of these I'll give you
another one I'll give I've got multiple
of these that's what I'm saying let's go
with that one he was a very clever guy
again for some reason the prophet mhmad
is a very intelligent we know it anyways
but alhamdulillah he knew it the prophet
Muhammad upon him also made specific
prophecies he said the hour will not
come until barefooted bedwin will be
racing with one another to build tall
buildings now he made it very specific
he did not say a nation would come and
build whole buildings he said barefooted
BNS will race with one another to build
tall buildings that's specific now
because if he said any Nation you can
think okay it can be skyscrapers
whatever ever now if you go to Dubai
Dubai 30 years ago was a desert if you
go and look at the ruler he has a
picture with his dad they are if if you
see the picture they are literally
barefooted standing on Sand him and his
father his father and his son where is
the toest building
today where's the second one being built
in Saudi 1 kilom long the prophet
Muhammad prophesized and said a day will
come where barefooted beduins will race
with one another to build tall buildings
that is exact what's happening today and
who are the barefooted bins the Arabs
and there's pictures of them 30 years
ago
barefooted chance he was lucky again
I'll give you another one another one I
mean it's quite easy not to not to wear
shoes and fulfill that prophecy like I
said like I said before brother if I
give you 100 you say it's easy
everyone's going to be
easy but Jack you know what is I know
that what I'm look when I saw these
things when I was looking to Islam two
of them was sufficient enough for me to
accept Islam I can't change your heart
look I you're human being you have your
own mind my job is not to convince you
but there might be people who there's
about a thousand people watching maybe
somebody there will say you know
actually this this can't be
possible Malik was a bounty hunter who
was hunting for the prophet Muhammad
when the Pagan arrows were chasing him I
want to tell you guys this and this is
mindblowing Sak Malik is chasing the
prophet Muhammad his horse for some
reason refuses to go forward he tells
the prophet Muhammad allow me I come in
peace cuz he's thinking there's
something wrong when he goes to the
prophet Muhammad why does the prophet
Muhammad say something
very bizarre he comes and says to him
and before he says anything the prophet
Muhammad says toik he says Glad Tidings
for the day that you are going to wear
the bracelets of KRA so he's thinking in
his head what let me give you context in
our terms so we understand it's like me
coming to you and saying I would imagine
if I was a prophet and I'm telling you a
day is going to come you are going to
conquer America and where Donald Trump's
Ro
next you start everyone start laughing
like this gu they're going I'm tapped in
the head this guy lost his mind the
prophet Muhammad the guy comes to him
out of he could have say anything they
could say how you doing you're right
okay good listen stop chasing us leave
us alone he says a day will come Sak
where you are going to wear the bracelet
of KRA who's KRA KRA is the the ruler of
Persia do you know
himra hisory yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah if
you know he's the ruler of KRA okay and
the second time they conquered do you
know who wore the bracelets
no wore bro he can can you imagine a
prophecy given they them conquering
Persia brother it's a dream we talking
about Persia massive Empire Rome brother
he's given a clear prophecy you are
going to wear and guess what Sak lived
that gu that guy could have died a year
two years later three years later and
the prophecy would be we would be asking
a question why did the prophet say
something that was not fulfilled he
fulfilled that prophecy brother there's
hundreds of these BR I can carry until
tomorrow so the point is this it comes
to a point where you come and say it is
not a possibility that it's a a chance
chance smart guy intelligent Guy come on
man how intelligent this is something
that is not from him it is from the
Divine he's he made these prophecies
with his wife and Ali AA and Ali when
they had the war they went to war
together the prophet Muhammad said to
Aisha said to Ali he said you are going
to go to war with my wife and Ali said
what a Wretched Man I'm going to be me
to go war with your wife the prophet
said no rather that day you're going to
be correct you're going to be on the
right side yeah this happened in the
Battle of Jamal Jamal that's what it's
called yeah the battle of the camel the
prophet Ali and Aisha went to war and
specifically the prophet told AA and
when the dogs are barking or something
along those lines return to your home
when Aisha was seen these are in our
narrations Aisha when was when I heard
the dogs barking I remembered what the
prophet said I returned to my house
brother how does he know this stuff he
knew stuff where he talked about two
battles between muaah and uh Ali yeah he
predicted brother the war he predicted
the person he said to one of them he
said you are going to join the ranks of
the righteous and you're going to be
killed at their hands brother there I
can give you multiple there's a book
called the signs of the day of out day
of judgment yeah bro there's one it says
there will come a day where people will
be dressed by naked how can he be
dressed by Naked Brother go and see now
how I mean you don't need to see it
brother har don't look here but you get
what I'm trying to say so what I'm
seeing is it is not possible for a
logical rational person to look at this
and say chance ch ch ch ch how many ch
do you have bro so to me I believe this
is why my evidence the quran's
preservation it's Miracles it's
prophecies it is not by man and the
Bible does not meet this challenge the
Bible is corrupted it's added by books
mankind is written there's false
prophecies so the Quran is not like the
Christianity and I brought my
evidence I would like to know because I
don't know anything yeah um what's your
definition of the Jihad and do you argue
that sometime it's misinterpreted it is
Mis interpreted but Jihad is in Islam
what does Jihad mean they say holy war
but not the holy war that you see of
Isis and all these other people doing
atrocities this is not a part of our
religion so with us Jihad is a righteous
War it's a war against oppression it's
not about I'm going to go and put a bomb
on myself it's not from Islam suicide is
you're not allowed to kill yourself let
allow someone else so it's been hijacked
and this war on ter we saw the who R the
rules harrisa President Bush Tony Blair
who have killed atrocities it's I find
it very bizarre they commit crimes in
Iraq one million people Afghanistan half
a billion million Burma is Palestine
Burma wegers and we are the called the
terrorists you can't make the stuff up
bro they are killing M Muslims in the
millions and we're called terrorists
they are the biggest terrorist in W and
now the world because of social media
are seeing the reality they know who the
real terrorists are everyone's waking up
today now they're looking and thinking
we've been sleeping they lied to us
about Iraq Afghanistan Mass explosions
of um yes all of this stuff was Li
Muslims we are supposed to be the ones
that are killing men women and children
brother you see what's going in Israel
and the whole entire world is seeing now
through the real terrorists are and it's
Israel and the Christian lobbies
supporting them so alhamdulillah with
our religion bro you will not find a
single text that tells you kill men
women or children the prophet Muhammad
forbade he told Abu Bakr clearly you are
not allowed to kill men woman bees trees
children is Haram you're not allowed to
you are not allowed to harm these people
go to Christianity and Judaism it gives
you direct commandment kill anybody what
do you think they're do in Israel what
they're doing is not from a hatred from
theel they actually believe this they
believe these people are inferior they
don't care they think God's chosen
people they're killing men women and
children bro happily and they say yeah
we want to kill
more yeah thank you sir nice talking to
you thank talking